So do it's phenomenal [you] know just be out here. I'm looking over there at the trees like I can't believe trees get that tall
till we make
We hear it. We say it. We believe it, but can we see the effect
The games online you can see in a person's eyes. It's noticeable if they make the players around them better
the effector
Welcome to the [Inn] Factory
for the quarterbacks when they arrive at the opening the mentality is that
We've kind of been through the fire all [twelve] quarterbacks are in the [elite] [Eleven] class for 2016
But also the competition is still on is they are all seeking to become the MVP and dominate in the Seven-on-seven
Competition my expectation coming to the opening is be precise and have the same chip on the shoulder
That I did in La if you look literally on your smartphone and looked up the [word] compete it would say to strive against
But he go way back and look at the latin root of the word like where the word actually began. It's defined as striving together
So like we said the first day the very first day you guys met everybody at your regional camp
Then you made it to Los angeles for the [Li] Eleven finals now here at the opening
It's all about the [twelve] best competitors who can make one another better?
How do we strive together to have the most amazing week under the sun?
The greatest Dynamic we see every year the opening is this we see guys shrink and we see guys rise up
We've had a lot of big fishes and small palms is a big-ass pond
And you got to be a big-ass fish
to have commander your teams
I'm thankful to be here
I really am I think it was so many talented guys out there that very well could have been in our shoes
But I think um it's a great [opportunity] and a great chance to further some bonds
I made in La we all share a unique Bond
We just feel comfortable around each other we can goof around and when we need to be serious we [can] be stuff
It's fun to all have the same Mindset [still] competing for the MVP
But everyone's realizing. We're all in the same boat were the only people that are experiencing this and it's something
We're gonna enjoy, and how's the fun out [here]?
as
We get here for a few days before all the athletes show up in the [games] start
[we] have these three really robust days of training
This is as [good] of opportunity as you're gonna get to improve as you will ever have
So what I would say to you guys I have an open mind, and I'm gonna learn as much as I possibly be
This is as close to a college environment that these guys are gonna have this is a finesse play
This is watch. How crafty I am
whoo
Awesome don's on out, huh?
He's chill like to go stanford again like that's a prototypical what they look like hey
And when throws to its crazies guys are in high school
So what you're doing is you're swinging your left arm down
Causing your moves control the ball so when you warm up tomorrow tuck your thumb and your [dreyfus] like this yeah hold the ball
normal carriage and throw see how the different is
The second higgins opening is [what] we [want] throw the ball. Yeah
Nearly cannot [doll] that ball any better than you beautiful. That's the tempo. Oh there we go
really Adamant about
Maximizing every minute of the teaching you know at the end of the day um just have fun just enjoy high school
We want to use the counselors wisdom and information to help these kids grow you live in a world of [competition] and competition is good
but it can become
Unhealthy when you let it consume you and you worry so much about what?
Critics are saying about you what other people think about you, and you've got to learn
How to manage that you know all [of] you guys are definitely high recruited highly talented when you step on campus?
Everyone will know who you are get a text message as I pay demanding saying hey, good luck me
I'll see you on the sidelines. I'll be there today, but just want to wish you good luck. It was like. That's [painting] man
I don't even know with the text back
crazy stuff by Dad I
Know I found my purpose and my why am I reasoning why I'm in this position
And it's not to be great on the football field is
inspire young people and
Share my story, [or] what I went through so
People from you know my hood my hometown that never made it out can have hope and dreams
La was one thing [to] [hear] at the opening the coaching is unbelievable as a defensive
Perspective how we looked at things
my job was to [soli] was you guys up and
[the] see if you were scared if you were weak
It was my job to make you quit
Willie's a no-nonsense guy he doesn't
Sugarcoat a lot of stuff and he didn't sugarcoat it with the kids like [hey], you want to in fact her toughness Tom Brady
He didn't look like an athlete
But mentally he was one of the toughest mother you ever meet [you] know any month and one of the most competitive
Guys, you'll ever meet now that you're here. Don't be satisfied with [that] Fellas
You got to go above and Beyond
The people that truly know the if factor within their son are the ones that raise them
so our staff
Asked the parents and the guardians to send a letter in of what they love about their son what they admire about their son
Why they are so excited about the future of their son
Every Kid you get true emotion?
You get a beyond the x's and o's moment
This is way bigger than football
as
We had a conversation with the quarterbacks after they read the letter [you]
[realized] how emotional and how impactful parents can be just being able to get the opportunity to
He's finally here from my mom you know with with just everything that's going on her side, you know
means a lot for
Me it was the opposite. No. Yeah, always here my mom
You know she's a lovely person this uh she's an equipment mom
[and] I don't always get the the kind of the feeling things from [a] dad
And she's touching to hear from him
Sam we all saw your story. What was it like reading a letter from your mom actually she put a letter
From my dad in there, and so that kind of hit me pretty deep just from a from a while ago
And that [just] made me realize that
All this is great and all this
But it doesn't mean anything unless you have family in a support system, and I'm just very thankful for that
it was like the first line, and I read it my mom [says] she was proud of me and
Just hearing it until it's kind of I don't know it is like it hit me and then her bringing up avery
Huffman who passed away from the cancer that wasn't curable and I dedicated my season to her
It's that kind of just came walk back to me
The point is is that all too often in our race to become a lead they sometimes?
Can forget the things that really matter along the way?
[Niju] is amazing foundation of my hometown stands for never ever give up and we
focused our efforts on
children battling cancer
Some local courageous kids who are battling some tough stuff right [now] come and have an amazing day with us
But then on the other side of it these young developing quarterbacks
Get to have an experience where they are hit right in the face something. That's very real very raw
Just like you [I] work out a lot
By not working out to play in a football game
I'm working out to get better
So when you give me a high five [a] fist bump or even a pat on the back
Post me to need you when I work out [my] needle we spent our number. I'm not alone. I need you to you
every kid
That has cancer deserves to be encouraged to never ever give [up]
You're gonna meet some [of] the most courageous kids that are for the moment that you spend with them
They won't think that they have cancer
And that is a great day
We're gonna put them through a little skills competition right here while [high-energy] fired up this is their BCS national championship game today
It's the biggest moment of their football [careers] put a hole in that thing
Leigha which was my partner and [I] know
She didn't want to go through the thing without holding my hand so I kind of went out there with her
She's seen that they put smile on my face and lifting me up some
[do] you put some things in perspective?
Everyone wants to be the best here, but it's really not about us, and it's not about
Anything that we're gonna accomplish. It's more about while we're accomplishing great things
Who we can touch on the way?
[and] Sean gave his joy jar to his courageous kid and the first thing
She did was take the first way out and give it to somebody else are you that?
You give it to him
That's so nice of you
she went over to her little brother in the
Stroller and put it on him and like gave it to him I kind of just like
They're just like wow this this girl does not care [about] what's going on
She just wants to be there [for] anyone else, so I'm kind of you know hit me in the heart
It's so cool to see these quarterbacks get inspired [by] the heart and the fight that these kids have
Nike's Campus the Pack House
Can you deal when it gets hard that is what Seven-on-seven?
[its] gonna prove to us as we figure [out] who the [MVP] is your choice offense. Well, we got the ball
It's the best group of pastors. We've ever had one through 12
There's not a ton separating ball from one so they are primed and ready to go
I think it goes back to when you're a little kid when you're playing recess football when you're playing in the backyard
To be elite to do have to be ultimate competitor
Kind of a gamer mentality where as soon as the whistle blows and [you] just breathe focus explode
Whenever you're in these kinds of competitive environments what you want to do. You want to do what you do best?
That's where the you know the real competitors come through the more intense the moment the more pure. They are to who they are
You'll be in a dilemma. You have it people feel that people sense it, but it's not just about you
It's about the [people] around so the MVP of the [elite] 11 the openings Gonna have to deal and it deal with coaches
They're a deal with players and it deal with TV cameras everywhere
The guy that does that's Gonna let the nep
Best [news] in the country have fun play loose
Alignment assignment and let it go in the past at the opening that the quarterback that's risen to the occasion is
capturing the 1180 people no go
You don't have to win it to be the MVP but it certainly helps
[Ed] coach let's run that bullet again. I like that
Might fall to him to attack [up] viola has a great body of work. He started building towards the ends of today
Rip really good play sean Sean clifford had a awesome day. He made some great throws. He was a leader
Besides [jake] problem, I thought he had the second-best day by far. Oh
Yeah, yeah, bart. We saw jake from today come out and light the world on fire
[I] normally don't say a whole lot about throws [oh], oh yeah. Oh, yeah
Davis mills also turned it on towards the end create a sign. Oh yeah
Also back on Tobacco hustle back hustle back James don't worry about the ball. [oh]
We're in those situations. I know I'm the coach and I'm getting everybody lined up
But I would love as you grow when you get older and to have more of a presence
[I] guess I'm just used to that just yeah, and when you're the clemson
And you're competing as a freshman you don't have a presence
And it's even with the guy who does go with [the] [guys] presence
you know I mean so just
Kind of Exert yourself a little bit more guys that were out in front did not perform as well
And pool play on day one that it allowed other guys to catch up oh
Never leave that short throw it into a bush [afford] leader short, [huh] he handles himself in a very mature way
But I don't he does not like to lose at all
Hey, we're working week the Hallway post corner to shallow right there my eyes there right away
Yeah, yeah, we're just going post corner [turn] shallow
Don't get so caught up with my third doing do your job and do it well
You did it great early in the week?
Trey's absolute right. That's why this is here
We got to keep doing this we don't want to new peaks here because every time [we're] out there
We got to get a little bit better. It's competitive as he is as much as he wants to win
This he actually didn't let the adversity from game one suck the energy out of his game [or] his teammates game
[cotter]
He's a kid. That's not afraid to have a setback for him from
You know he's someone. I think expects that he expects greatness out of himself and he's not surprised by
Win that hey wait a minute. Look good wait a minute look at me
Overall I am very very proud of how you guys handle the day but tomorrow
You got to make sure you control it you can control and that you
Communicate with these guys all the time there is no such thing as a quiet
quarterback leader
There's just no such thing
The streets are littered with five star quarterbacks that didn't have that it
So we play these games on the final day
This is what I want. It's very clear. I want decisiveness
When you make a decision make it don't doubt it
Let it Rip
You're in control of your experience tomorrow make it awesome
It was really tough do [it] here you've seen a lot of football in your life your pedigree is built for this you got me
You know I believe in yourself all the guys leave you bleeding your booty god's gonna. Do what you do sir. He got me yep
That's it. [I] think [this] job. Let's go put it a sign. [oh] stairs stairs there
You got thrown earlier
Hey, if it's not there, [just] drops from the corner. We worked on [that] to throw the L. It came wide open
Yesterday I got away with a bunch of stuff and today honest, I still felt I did my job
I [really] [just] didn't just think there's nothing there was nothing beyond. Just your job today. Which is some of those days like that
We have the two guys that came in one or two [two] otago by aloha and the Davis Mills
Competing for the championship and the MVP this [whole] competition has been closed now it [has] in the championship game
[we've] made it so close that we're gonna term the MVP of Elite 11 by this game. Yes, sir
All right, just appreciate [it] coach. Thank you fallout. Amen go get he love you bill. Have fun
It's not everybody ain't everybody and it's [gold]. God is good. God is good. All God is good
Oh, that's good. All the time all the time [go] big, Ol be going through one two three go. Let's go boys
Good
Seem get back you go get him in space hit his face. Oh yeah, yeah yeah yeah, yeah, yeah, ghee?
oh
they're long -
Hey, we got one play to get inside the twenties ever understand that okay one play to get inside the 20 and then we're good
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah there y'all hey great job, buddy
They gotta do something to disrupt their time your night out
Good job boys. Good job. Good job
Hey, thanks, right appreciate it
Preciate it customer priority goes appreciated. Thank you guys
Good
Your journey to be here
in Football Heaven
started with some hard lonely work, so we're saying that to a stand up [I]
challenge you about six weeks ago to stand up I
Said you're a heck of a football player. You're incredible athlete, but I didn't see the discipline in your game to be a quarterback
It could not have been more wrong and I'm so happy. I was wrong of all the kids I've ever coached
I've never seen one [improve] more rapidly
You have uniqueness in you
Your arm talent is supreme. I think it pales in comparison to what you have in here
You have something really special in here, and you will change the world. I'm so proud of you that you're the 2016 11
The it [Factory] we hear it. We hear it. We hear it. We
[say] it. We say it. We say it. We believe it
But can we see it?
Some argue yes, of course
It's right in front others say oh, no this thing cannot be captured and it's nowhere near a playbook, and it's nowhere near a book
So this is factor the most undefinable overused phrase how do we quantify it?
How do we quantify it frank it [rank] it rank it or simply say see
the it Factor [Dia] Factor
So [let's] agree
Okay
Factor is something we can't describe
Something we can't describe other than something because we see [to] [Sharlee] to develop the develop to develop to develop
to nurture to nurture to nurture to learn all about
So this is factor the most undefinable overused phrase has gained so much clout on TV in staff rooms on draft
yawns
As women we have a really different it factor for you. We want a man who stands for something that's bigger [than] himself
Viet Factor the effector. They factor
This phrase it's the ever undefinable phrase
Now some say you either have it or you don't [either]
Have it or you don't [you're] gonna be this won't be that you either have it or you don't
hear Factory
[no] [one] ever [says] whomped hears about diving in the lonely work the love of doing the boring things
Longer than the other the lonely work
And it's developed under the bright lights and dimly lit ones now
Let's be clear okay to be a leak it must compete to be elite
You must compete so when you do tap in so you do deaf [and] do it for real
Dig I know it hurts?
Nice draw do for real do it for real so don't that's football. That's it
the effect
The effector the effect say Da bomb say it out loud the hip factor the effector in fact the effector the most
Undefinable overuse race it's a place where we embrace grip. It's not a summer case not a summer
It's the place where we develop our it
Welcome to the it [factory]
you